قالت افتتاحيه صحيفتها ارس الاسرائيليه
انه يجب على اسرائيل ان تسمح بدخول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى غزه وتابعت ان
نصف سكان قطاع غزه اي حوالي مليون شخص
يعانون حاليا الجوع الشديد حسب الامم
المتحده وهذه كارثه انسانيه لم يسبق لها
مثيل في جولات القتال السابقه وهو وضع
يلزم اسرائيل بتقليل الاضرار التي لحقت
بالسكان المدنيين قدر الامكان حسبها
ارتس في حوار مع صحيفه لوموند قال
دبلوماسي الامريكي السابق ارون ديفيد ميلر
انه اذا ارادت الولايات المتحده ممارسه
تاثير حقيقي على استراتيجيه اسرائيل في
غزه فعليها اولا ابطاء او منع عمليات
تسليم الاسلحه والذخائر وبعد ذلك تاييد
قرار من مجلس الامن يتناول البعد السياسي
للحرب واخيرا عليها حمل الاسرائيليين على
قبول الواقع وهو بالتحديد استحاله تدمير
حماس والحاجه الى قبول وقف الاعمال
العدائيه تحت عنوان استراتيجيه بايدن
المضطربه في غزه الولايات المتحده تبدو
عاجزه نقرا في صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز ان
نهج الاداره الامريكيه كان دعم اسرائيل في
العلن والحث على توخي الحذر في السر لكنها
الان تواجه قلقا وانتقادا متزايده داخل
امريكا وخارجها واشار المقال الى انه على
عكس الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا لم يكن لدى
بايدن الوقت للاستعداد للحرب في غزه لقد
كانت هزه غير متوقعه في وقت كان فيه البيت
الابيض يعتقد ان منطقه الشرق الاوسط
مستقره
نسبيا راى تحليل في مجله فورين افيرز ان
الولايات المتحده في تعاملها مع الصراع
الاسرائيلي الفل يني ليس امامها طريق سهل
للخروج من عنق الزجاجه واذا اراد الرئيس
جو بايدن الحل فيجب على ادارته اتخاذ
خطوات سياسيه اكثر جراه واتباع تحركات
توجه المنطقه بحزم نحو حل الدولتين ويعتبر
التحليل ان القياده الامريكيه الجريئه
الان هي وحدها القادره على دعم التوصل الى
نتيجه جيده في اعقاب هذه
الحرب
مع مقتل ما يقرب من 70 صحفيا من سيبقى
لتغطيه الحرب في غزه هكذا يتساءل مقال راي
في صحيفه لوس انجلس تايمز مشيرا الى
اتفاقيه جنيف التي تنص على حمايه المدنيين
والصحفيين اثناء النزاعات مسلحه لكن في
غزه يبدو الامر كما لو ان الصحفيين
يعاملون كمقاتلين وباتت وفاتهم مجرد ارقام
تحسب من بين حصيله القتلى ويلفت المق الى
ان هؤلاء الصحفيين كانوا ينقلون المعلومات
للعالم ويقدمون فهما ولقطات للهجوم
الاسرائيلي المتواصل الذي لا تستطيع
الارقام والاحصائيات وحدها
[موسيقى]
التقاطه